長はですねお待たせしましたよっ
あのーずーっとバイクでてたんですけどもうあの謎の意味不明ゲーム始め23の
アップデートがついに本日からスタートでございますぅー do
で僕が実践者のプレイして見せちゃってもあれなのですがプレイの映像は見せないん
ですけどもまぁ何が変わったかといいますとまず一つ目
広告が少なくなりましたよ4
それはぁで本当に何か航空がが多いって意見もあったんですけれどもやっぱり効果が
ないとねアプリっていうのは成り立たないところもあるので
けどまぁ極力減らすようにちょっと色々工夫をした感じでございます
でもう一つなんですけどもあのカミカミノンまでたどり着いて終わったんですよね
アップデート前は神で立つってはたんですけど神になった後の話が今回パップデートで
増えております何とですね
藤蔵キャラクターが約2倍にピックって
さらに
私初めに者もなってる者なんで笑ってんがっちはじゅにーさんは困難大花木 a と
いうことで大きく音アプリ末進化したということでまぁ日本一だった3でプレイ
1234567 s 90まで行って
なにこの番パターン焼ければ不思議な世界観だからそこを楽しめるでよかったと思うん
ですけどもさらにそれプラスお酒の話も楽しめるということでですね
まあこのいろいろとね深い要素までも盛り込めたということでですね
ですね始め23全く意味不明なゲームですけど前より母もはるかに高
深い話になってるんでよかったら楽しんで頂け
いうとありがたいでございます動画の説明何からインストールできます
top 8モーニンソルしで2分アップで撮っていきます
アンドロイとそして ios すべてか利用しておりますので良かったらぜひね
ダウンロードしていただけれできます
じゃあな
ダボの
4日